OUTFRONT tonight, Russia is hiring
as a top Putin mouthpiece
offers Tucker Carlson
a job with Russian state television.
The most senior Russian official
to visit the United States
since Putin invaded Ukraine.
You heard me there today
said this unprompted
holds nothing other than perhaps
it would be useful to consider
how things are with freedom of speech
in the United States.
I've heard that Tucker Carlson has left
Fox News.
It's curious news.
What is this related to?
One can only guess.
But clearly, the wealth of views
in the American information
space has suffered as a result of
That's the foreign minister
for Vladimir Putin, Sergei Lavrov.
The all that's going on here
in the United States
coming here
talking about the loss of Tucker Carlson.
It's unbelievable, right?
I mean, it's incredible that he would
do such a thing. And weigh on this.
Why is Lavrov obsessed
specifically with Tucker Carlson?
Well, you may ask, why is that because in
Russia, Tucker Carlson is a star
for repeatedly being pro-Russian,
anti-American and anti Ukraine.
Listen to this.
Might be worth asking yourself,
since it is getting pretty serious.
What is this really about?
Why do I hate Putin so much?
Has Putin ever called me a racist
as he threatened to get me fired
for disagreeing with him?
Does he eat dogs?
These are fair questions.
And the answer to all of them is no.
Vladimir Putin didn't do any of that.
The Russians don't want
American missiles on their border.
They don't want a hostile government
next door.
Ideologues within the Biden
administration did not want
a negotiated peace in Ukraine.
They wanted all along.
And it's very clear
now a regime change, war against Russia
Maybe they just wanted no water, right?
Just respect the border.
So here's the thing.
Since the start of the war, Russia's state
media has been using things like that.
Tucker Carlson, to prove
and to bolster their points.
The two, frankly, have been in lockstep
on their spin.
Watch this
if there is any single
American who deserves scorn and,
yes, blame for the invasion of Ukraine.
It would be Joe Biden.
That's the time right now.
We need to introduce a new term.
Biden's war equipment.
Why not Biden?
It's Biden's war. He's in charge.
Should the word for word.
And look at this from reporter
Julia Davis.
She does incredible work
monitoring Russian propaganda.
She points out.
Look at this here.
This is these are different pictures
from Russian state television.
Julius found all of these.
Tucker
Carlson in every one of them at the center
of Russian state television
is messaging again and again and again.
I mean, look at these images of Carlson's
face up on the big screen.
In their studios in Moscow
while the host fallen over Carson's
rhetoric about Russia and Ukraine,
which is why the highest
ranking Russian official
to come to the United States
since the war began.
The foreign minister is seizing
on the fact that Tucker Carlson
no longer has a megaphone,
or at least for now,
they're offering him a job.
What's even more offensive than Lavrov
portraying Carlson
as a symbol of freedom of speech,
though, is his government's treatment
of Putin critics and journalists,
including The Wall Street
Journal reporter Evan Miscovich.
Today, our Matthew Chance
was there with Lavrov and pressed him
on a possible prisoner swap for Americans
Gorse Kasich, as well as Paul Wheeling,
U.S. Americans.
You could ask them
in the Russian Federation,
there are several
American citizens who are serving
sentences for various crimes.
I refer to Paul Whelan and Evan Gerst,
which they were detained
when they were committing
a crime, receiving material
that was a state secret.
And the vociferous,
pathos laced statements
about journalists, by definition,
and not being able to commit crimes
is something which we reject disorders.
All right.
Matthew Chance was the one who asked
that question of the foreign minister.
You know him, of course,
who spent so much time in Moscow
as well as Ukraine during this war.
And he's with me here.
And Matthew,
I want to ask you about that exchange
that you had with Lavrov,
because it just isn't true anymore
that anyone even gets to ask him
questions.
Writes, is a very rare opportunity.
But first, Tucker Carlson,
he brings up Foreign Minister
Lavrov brings up Tucker Carlson.
And you have spent so much time
there in Moscow.
You know that state media there
obviously is long lauded Carlson.
Right. He's been valuable to them.
What did you make of Lavrov
bringing this up today?
Well, I think it underlines
just how valuable that is to them
and how much of a sort of voice
he is on Russian state media.
We saw there from the reporting
that we've just, you know, featured.
He is a regular feature of Russian state
television newscasts
and Russian anchors use his views,
which are often, you know, quite extreme
in some cases
as the views of reasonable America.
The reasonable West.
And I think one of the reasons
that Lavrov is so upset
that Tucker Carlson is no longer on the
on the air
at the moment, at least,
is he's such a disrupter as well.
And the Russians, you know,
they back disrupters.
They want to disrupt themselves.
And so this is a
you know, he was doing a lot of the work.
The Kremlin media would have
would have loved to have done.
And so absolutely.
To tell Russians, oh, it's
this is being said in America
that all of a sudden
it gives you bolsters that.
Now, let me ask you about the exchange
that you had with Lavrov
because this is crucial.
We've heard nothing from them.
They never talk about
what they would be willing to do,
whether it be for Paul Whalen or Evan
Miscovich among the Americans
who are imprisoned there right now.
You asked Lavrov
if a prisoner exchange was possible.
What did he tell you?
Well, look, I mean, there have been
prisoner exchanges in the in the past.
In the recent past,
Brittney Griner was absolutely a prominent
Russian basically here.
And so that's the expectation.
The trouble is with Victor Boost,
the most high profile of Russians
that was in a Russian US
jail already swapped.
One of the problems that Ivan Gersh
Kovic and Paul Williams got is, well,
who is who can
they be swapped with? Right.
And we struggle to answer this.
And so Sergei Lavrov,
I asked him this question,
what does he want in exchange
for these two American citizens?
Listen to what he had to say.
60. This titular
we have approximately 60 people
who are serving sentences here,
which is your solution.
And in most cases,
the accusations are dubious
So 60
people I've not heard that number four.
I mean, that was you
don't just put out a number by accident.
You're him, right?
He was prepared with the number he was and
and so clearly they have the idea
that if there's going to be a prisoner
swap, it is going to be these two people.
60 to two.
Well, I mean, let a chunk of people
a big group of people
put what they've got left or right.
Well, pretty amazing.
And obviously he came right.
That that was he was going to ask
that answer that had someone to ask.
And of course, you were the one who asked.
Matthew Chance, thank you very much.
And now I want to go to Julia Davis.
I mentioned her, a Russian media analyst.
She's the
creator of the Russian Media Monitor,
also a columnist for The Daily Beast.
She has been sanctioned by Russia
and retired U.S.
Air Force Colonel Cedric Leighton,
a former intelligence officer.
And Julia, you know, your work during
all of this has just been incredible,
the things that you see and find
and hear on Russian media
as you consume so much of what Russians
are being faced with every day.
So Lavrov brings up Tucker
Carlson unsolicited today.
And you've been following
how the Russian propaganda
machine is weaponized
Carlson and used him throughout the war.
What impact does his
firing have on that machine?
Well, they
have been
latched on to Tucker Carlson for years,
and it really intensified
after Russia invaded Ukraine.
Lately, they have not had a single show
where Tucker Carlson segments
didn't prominently figure in them.
It was constant.
And why it works for them so well
is on Russian state television.
They always blame America for everything.
They never criticize Putin or Russia,
and neither does Tucker Carlson.
So everything he says, it sounds like
it was written by the Kremlin.
It's perfect for them.
And they always mention
that he had an enormous viewership
and the way they have been able
to influence Americans
without lifting a finger.
Just through Tucker Carlson's
talking points that conveniently aligned
with theirs. Yeah.
And you say conveniently aligned.
I mean, Colonel,
the word echo is pretty incredible, right,
between Tucker Carlson and other Russian
propagandists that we see on state media.
Let me play again this
if there is any single American
who deserves scorn and,
yes, blame for the invasion of Ukraine,
it would be Joe Biden.
That's why now we need to introduce
a new term, Biden's war equipment.
Why not Biden? It's Biden's war.
He's in charge of this, colonel,
from a military standpoint.
How much damage do the words of Carlson
do to American goals when you look at how
this is being propagated
to the Russian public,
Yeah, and they are pretty considerable.
And this is a classic disinformation
campaign.
So when you look at how the Russians
couched this in their media,
you know, as Julia has mentioned,
and it's very clear
that there are certain things
that they want to achieve.
And one of those things
is the division of our society.
And I found some interesting statistics
on defense, one
where they talk about a poll
where a great deal of people
having a great deal or not a great deal
of confidence in the military.
And over the years,
that number has decreased from 70%
having a great deal of conference
confidence in the military down
to a low of 45% I did
that was just recently.
So when you look at those kinds of things,
it has an absolute effect
on people's perceptions and people's
willingness to support bigger policy.